hey pal you ready to go
whoa you look amazing and your hair is
fire
all right nobody move
who did it
did what zack
who parked in my space
excuse me
but i think you've made a big mistake
oh yeah
yeah
you parked your bike in my parking space
was your name on it
oh let me explain something i'm zack
morris
should i be impressed
okay i'm sorry mac but i got that
parking space fair and square uh i
wouldn't call that fair you drugged my
toothpaste and i woke up at six flags
once i'm there i'm not just gonna leave
this means war lexi
parking spot war oh you're on preppy
yeah i will rob you of your sanity and
lovingly nurse you back to health only
to destroy you again
detention
just kelly and me
a dream come true
[Music]
hello zach i've been waiting for you
i couldn't even imagine if you never
came to this school
uh oh miss mandrake i didn't do my
homework homework we even had homework
since you outlawed it oh wise leader
oh yeah i forgot
and if i'm elected student body
president i promise to uphold our school
constitution
and i promise to promote a healthier
more productive environment by removing
all products with artificial ingredients
from school vending machines thank you
[Applause]
hey regarding our school constitution
who cares
that's artificial ingredients hey i
think they've gotten a bum wrap but do
you want to live a life without pizza
nachos or hot dogs
hey buddy
wait you're running for president yeah
according to the student manual class
president gets the parking spot right in
front of school which is even better
than the parking spot we were previously
fighting over that's why i'm running as
well
you know what's weird how we both met a
girl and fell in love on the same day
statistically it was bound to happen
[Music]
hey braby
there she is
hey you know julia
yeah i know joanna she's a girl i've
been telling you about
no no no she's the girl i've been
telling you about
hey slater
yes you went into the senior party yet
no
no
joanna would you like to go to the
senior kickoff party with me
that was gonna be the perfect day for me
and pamela wait your girl's name is
pamela that's my girl's name too wait
but that means
we only have to write one valentine's
day rap yeah yes
it's the same pamela idiots
okay
no my girl is like this
exactly and my pamela is like this
no
right good work screech here you go
okay martha here's your 20 dollars
go to it
ac honey
i thought you invited me to the movies
who are you
my son the kidder he just loves pulling
mom's legs
is this your mom
no
i've never met this woman before in my
life
how could you treat me this way
on my birthday
birthday what
spider we can go out another time if
it's your mother's birthday she is not
my mother
keep it quiet down here
oh hi mrs slater ah
she's not my mother oh is she pulling
your leg again mrs ass oh the guy never
quits
is this slater i'm joanna why don't you
take my seat the movie's gonna start
soon
oh hey jamie isn't uh pamela in this
class the
object of our gentleman's prank war is
she hmm i hadn't realized
[Music]
uh hey dude um no offense but you smell
like hella dog poop
yeah i should hope so
i've been volunteering at an animal
rescue hey girl this is for you
what
i think i was here first i don't think
so let go son before i make you wear it
oh
i mean like this
no
i meant like this
well if you did that then i'm gonna have
to do this
[Applause]
well
then i just have to do this
hey hey hey hey what is going on here
nothing a black eye configuration
look at you
look trevor you're all wet yeah you too
oh oh man we look really stupid
where's your girlfriend loser where's
your girlfriend oh wait that's right she
doesn't exist
just like santa i found out recently hey
first off is real bro he exists in the
hearts of all who believe and second off
this
joke's on you my penis was hot anyways
[Music]
so what's it gonna be fellas uh
just the coke i'm not really hungry
is something wrong
no
no you're failing and when the principal
meets your dad you won't be able to go
on the ski trip
well it'll be sadder than the end of e.t
if you were my son i'd let you go skiing
you would
in
oh right on time zach mr belding
this is my father
dad
hello i'm derek morris
okay so what's the plan what do you
think we could try swedish backpack no
the school doesn't have a boiler room
how about a three-finger sally not close
enough to a body of water plus my
passport's expired what the hell are you
talking about these are classic schemes
daisy yeah if we explain our shorthand
then it defeats the purpose of a
shorthand or a sherlock pop which is
shorthand for shorthand
okay we just need to hurry my mom's
shift ends at poor so she'll probably
call dr spano back then well if we're
that short a bump up on time there's
really only one way to go the giraffe's
gambit we'll need an actress to play
your mom but i don't know any actresses
oh
my aunt was on the news after raccoons
to her bra
okay
no too short no way too tall oh i love
her but not for this mm-hmm would you
ever consider her being a russian 24
year old with big falsies my mom
no okay well if you're gonna be so picky
then which one of these women looks most
like your mom
the only latina one well creatively it
just feels like a safe choice
but it's fine
are you dr spano i'm daisy's mom
oh it's so lovely to meet you thank you
for showing an interest in my daughter
daisy sofia jimenez who was born in the
los angeles county hospital on july 12
2005.
of course should we step into my office
uh it's actually a custom among my
people that we go for a walk outside
when we first meet a person
and i feel uncomfortable questioning you
on that so let's do it
why couldn't you just be straight with
me why can you just tell me you were
having trouble in school dad i try to
tell you look you're not that easy to
talk to
you used to tell me everything what
happened to us
excuse me son that's what's happened to
us
uh yeah
charlie could you uh call me back in a
few minutes yeah me too i just need to
get through to my dad is he not
listening to you no i mean literally get
through to my dad i've been on hold with
his office for 16 hours
that's him playing the sacks
cool yeah
yeah sure if i if i meet him in san
francisco this weekend
i'm assured of the deal that's great you
tell him
charlie you tell them uh
i can't make it this weekend
i'm taking my son fishing
yeah
[Music]
and you will remember
to bring your books won't you
dad
[Music]
hey dad
yes sir
do you think when you get back when you
do a prank together i heard this crazy
one where we take a baseball and i throw
it into your hands and you throw it into
mine and we do it until it gets dark and
then mom's like come in for dinner boys
and then we eat together
you know like as a prank
[Music]
yeah i like that
pie in your face my comrade
pie in your face my comrade
you